[موسيقى]
فجأة سأجد شخصًا يأتي ويقول لي
تعال من أجل سلسلة
الشاي السيلاني المشهور عالميًا حول
العالم
لمذاقه لجودة الشاي ،
لذلك عندما تقول شاي سيلاني تتوقع
كوبًا جيدًا من الشاي  مشروب جيد جدًا
[موسيقى]
ركن الشاي في جناح سري لانكا
يقدم لك
مجموعة من أنواع الشاي ويأتي من
جميع أنحاء الجزيرة
[موسيقى]
سفوح التلال لدينا
في بلداننا المرتفعة مغطاة جميعًا
بالسجاد الأخضر وهو
كل الشاي
هنا لدينا شاي سيلان
هنا ولدينا سبعة أنواع
مختلفة وهم يأتون من سبع
مناطق مختلفة في سريلانكا لذلك ينتقل من
قوي إلى فاتح كما ترون من
نظرة واحدة يمكنك رؤية الألوان
مختلفة وأيضًا  طعم
الرائحة مختلف أيضًا ،
لذلك يصفه بعض الناس بأنه
طعم ترابي جريء عندما تصل إلى
أسنان أقوى ،
ويصفه البعض الآخر بأنه أكثر
تهوية وأكثر الأزهار تقريبًا
كل شخص يأتي إلى هنا.  أتيت أنا منهم
للمرة الثانية
لأنهم يقولون إنهم يشعرون بأنهم في المنزل
يحبون تناول هذا الشاي
[موسيقى]